From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。
It's so embarrassing. I don't want to get upset. But like, he has a car. So the last time I saw him on purpose was just in the car in front of my house. I don't know. It's just bad.
太尴尬了。我不想让自己难过，但他有辆车。所以我最后一次故意去见他，就只是在我家门口的车里。我不知道，感觉糟透了。
Bad like when you walk out of your house you think like, there his car was?
那种“糟”是指当你走出家门时，你还在想他的车是不是停在那里吗？
Yeah. I still look for it. It's crazy. [LAUGHS]
是的，我还是会下意识地找那辆车。太疯狂了。[笑声]
OK. Now we're about a block from your house.
好了，我们离你家大概一个街区远了。
Like in front of that building right there. This like churchy-looking building was where we were parked when we first had the conversation where we decided we were going to be exclusive. Which was a joke. Like I don't really date around, and I don't think he does, either. But it's kind of a big conversation. But yeah, we were parked in the middle of that block right where that white car is.
就是那栋楼前面。那栋看起来像教堂的建筑，就是我们第一次谈话，决定要开始排他性约会的地方。那简直是个笑话，因为我本来就不怎么随便约会，我想他也是。但这确实是个重大的谈话。没错，我们就停在那条街中间，那辆白车停着的地方。
And so every time you walk down this street, you'll think like, oh yeah, there's the spot?
所以每次你走在这条街上，都会想：哦，就是这里？
I don't walk down this street. I just don't. Like I haven't even seen him for a month. You know what I mean?
我不走这条街，绝对不走。我已经一个月没见过他了，你明白吗？
When I walked around Lauren's neighborhood with her, it had been two months since her boyfriend broke up with her. They'd gone out for about 10 months before that. She was incredibly nice to let herself be taped in still a pretty raw state. But even in the middle of that raw state, she was acutely aware, and said herself that everything she was going through was a cliché-- a cliché that she was forced to live through.
当我和劳伦在她住的社区散步时，她和男友分手已经两个月了。在那之前，他们交往了大约10个月。她非常大方，愿意在自己情绪依然脆弱的状态下接受采访。但即使在那种脆弱的时刻，她也表现得非常清醒，她自己也说，她所经历的一切都是陈词滥调——一种她被迫去经历的陈词滥调。
That's the crazy thing about it. Breaking up with someone is literally the most common thing. Like everyone you know broke up with everyone they ever dated until maybe the person they're with right now, if they're with someone right now. But when it happens to you, it feels so specific. [LAUGHS] I don't want to say I can't get over it in like a flippant way. Like you kind of can't get over it. You're like, what? This is what's happening? It's so shocking.
这才是最疯狂的地方。和某人分手真的是再平常不过的事了。你认识的每一个人都和他们约会过的每一个人分过手，除非是现在正交往的那一个，如果他们有对象的话。但当这种事发生在你身上时，你会觉得这太特别了。[笑声] 我不想用一种轻浮的方式说我走不出来。因为你确实有点走不出来。你会想：什么？这是真的吗？太令人震惊了。
If I had to say one thing about Lauren, it's that she was full of feelings that completely contradicted each other, which I guess just comes with this territory. Like she emphatically did not want him to call. But also maybe a little bit wanted him to call. She missed him, and she didn't want to stop thinking about him. But she also did all this elaborate math to calculate the day that she would finally be over him and not thinking about him and with somebody else.
如果说劳伦有什么特点，那就是她充满了相互矛盾的情绪，我想这大概就是分手后的常态吧。她非常坚决地不想让他打电话来，但内心深处或许又有点希望他打来。她想念他，不想停止想他，但她又做了一大堆复杂的数学题，计算自己到底哪一天能彻底放下他，不再想他，并开始和别人交往。
We get to an area where she had been on walks with the ex-boyfriend. There are benches and a sidewalk promenade.
我们走到了她以前和前男友一起散步的地方。那里有一些长椅和人行道长廊。
I don't know. We used to just-- it's not that we took a ton of walks, but we took some walks.
我不知道。我们以前经常……倒也不是说我们走了很多路，但确实散过几次步。
And what happened down here?
那这儿发生过什么？
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
You know, I can't say that anything of substance happened. It's not like any one specific thing. It's just-- I don't know.
你知道，我不能说这里发生过什么实质性的事。也不是什么特定的某件事。只是……我不知道。
It's just that there was an us.
只是曾经有过一个“我们”。
I know. There really was. That's the thing that's so weird. It's like you put so much energy into something, and then one day, it's time to stop. I don't know.
我知道，确实有过。这才是最奇怪的地方。就像你对某件事投入了那么多精力，然后有一天，它必须结束了。我不知道。
During a breakup, you just stare at what happened. There's a before, and there's an after, and you just can't believe it. Lauren says she still doesn't even understand what went wrong between her and him. And that's part of it, too, so much of the time.
分手时，你只能盯着发生过的一切。有一个“之前”，有一个“之后”，而你无法相信这一切。劳伦说，她至今都不明白她和他是哪里出了问题。而这往往也是分手经历的一部分。
Well, we got the idea for today's radio show from an email that a listener sent. It says, "Dear This American Life, I'm suffering from a gut-wrenching breakup with my former boyfriend and I searched your site for shows about breakups and general heartbreak to commiserate, but to my surprise, I didn't find many stories specifically regarding the act of breaking up. I hope you consider it. A show like that would really cheer me up."
我们今天节目的灵感来自于一位听众发来的电子邮件。信里写道：“亲爱的《美国生活》，我正深受与前男友分手带来的痛苦折磨。我在你们网站上搜索关于分手和失恋的节目想寻求共鸣，但让我惊讶的是，并没有找到多少专门关于分手行为的故事。希望你们能考虑一下。这样的节目一定会让我振作起来。”
And so with that in mind, we devote our show today to breakups. Partly today, we have an anatomy of the completely contradictory feelings that are part of a breakup. I think that's what makes it such a special and particularly cursed state. And we have stories today about people trying in some very unusual, very resourceful ways to make themselves feel better during a breakup. The key word there would be "trying."
带着这个想法，我们今天的节目献给分手。在节目中，我们将剖析分手过程中那些极其矛盾的感受。我认为正是这一点让分手成为一种特殊且被诅咒的状态。今天我们还有一些故事，讲述人们试图通过一些非常规、非常有创意的方式在分手后让自己好过一点。重点在于“试图”这个词。
Our show today in four acts. In Act One, Starlee Kine heads out on a breakup mission unlike any we have ever heard of. In Act Two, an eight year old heads out into the world to get some answers about her parents' breakup. In Act Three, a man who has turned his back on the ways of his people-- his people, in this case, being divorce lawyers. Act Four, Merrill Markoe notes one possibly overlooked way to mend a broken heart, and it involves a soggy, plastic, disky thing. You'll just have to trust me on that one. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为四个部分。第一幕，斯塔莉·凯恩踏上了一次我们从未听闻过的分手任务。第二幕，一个八岁的小女孩向世界寻求关于父母分手的答案。第三幕，一个背离了同行之道的人——这里指的人是离婚律师。第四幕，梅里尔·马可指出了一个容易被忽略的治愈心碎的方法，它涉及到一个湿漉漉的、塑料的、圆盘状的东西。关于这个，你们就只能先相信我了。请留下来听我们节目。
Act One, Dr. Phil.
第一幕，菲尔博士。
When one of our regular contributors, Starlee Kine, was in the middle of getting over a breakup, she tried to feel better in a way that few people ever try, and that maybe even she shouldn't have. Here's Starlee.
当我们的一位常规撰稿人斯塔莉·凯恩正处于失恋中时，她尝试了一种很少有人会用，甚至可能她自己都不该用的方法来让自己好过点。下面是斯塔莉的报道。
Before I explain why I decided to write and record a breakup song even though I have no musical ability and can't play an instrument of any kind, I should probably explain a bit about the breakup itself. It was only after Anthony broke up with me that all the warning signs I had missed came sharply into focus. Like the time he told me he didn't like taking pictures of girlfriends because it was a downer to have those photos around once a relationship was over.
在我解释为什么我决定写一首分手歌——尽管我没有任何音乐天赋，也不会演奏任何乐器——之前，我应该先解释一下这次分手的经过。就在安东尼和我分手后，我才发现所有我之前忽略的警示信号都变得清晰起来。比如他曾经告诉我，他不喜欢给女朋友拍照，因为感情结束后留着这些照片会让人难过。
I'd had a crush on him since the day we met, but he always had a girlfriend in Canada. Then she broke up with him, and we got together. A week after that, he told me I was the one, which, in retrospect, was probably the biggest warning sign of all. It was, hands down, the corniest relationship I've ever been in. And by corniest, I mean greatest. We'd pass entire evenings just complimenting each other. We took hand-holding to new heights. And we listened to hours and hours of music, teenager style, playing one song after another while smiling a lot.
我们刚认识那天我就对他有好感，但他那时在加拿大有个女朋友。后来他们分手了，我们就在一起了。在那之后一周，他告诉我我是他的真命天女，现在回想起来，这可能是最大的警示信号。这毫无疑问是我经历过最俗套的恋爱了。我说“最俗套”，是指最棒的意思。我们可以花上一整个晚上赞美对方。我们把牵手带到了新的高度。我们像青少年一样听了几个小时的音乐，一首接一首地放，脸上挂着灿烂的笑容。
I don't quite remember how our Phil Collins phase began. I think it was one of those things that started off ironically, with Anthony lip-syncing, adorably, to "Against All Odds" one night. But over time, it became less and less ironic, until one day, we were actual fans.
我不记得我们是什么时候开始进入“菲尔·柯林斯阶段”的。我想这最初只是个玩笑，有一天晚上，安东尼可爱地对着《Against All Odds》假唱。但随着时间推移，这种玩笑越来越少，直到有一天，我们成了他的铁粉。
(SINGING) How can I just let you walk away, just let you leave without a trace, when I stand here taking every breath with you? Ooh, ooh. You're the only one who really knew me at all.
（演唱）我怎能让你就这样走开，让你不留痕迹地离开，当我站在这里，每一次呼吸都是为了你？哦，哦。你是唯一真正了解我的人。
We liked how honest and sad it was. "How can I just let you walk away, just let you leave without a trace? You're the only one who really knew me at all." We pictured Phil Collins at the piano writing it, the tears running down his face.
我们喜欢这首歌是因为它真实且悲伤。“我怎能让你就这样走开，让你不留痕迹地离开？你是唯一真正了解我的人。”我们脑海中浮现出菲尔·柯林斯在钢琴前写下这首歌时，泪水滑过脸庞的样子。
(SINGING) I wish I could just make you turn around, turn around and see me cry. There's so much I need to say to you, so many reasons why.
（演唱）我希望能让你转身，转身看我流泪。我有很多话要对你说，有很多理由。
Anthony broke up with me on New Year's Eve. I told you-- corny. I didn't really see it coming, and I definitely didn't want it to happen. He said, you're going to be OK. I just cried and cried. I wanted to stop it, to fix it. I searched deep inside myself for the right words to say, and out of my mouth popped this. How can you just let me walk away? I'm the only one who really knew you at all. And I meant it. In fact, I'd go so far as to say that, in that moment, no one could have conveyed how I was feeling better than Phil Collins.
安东尼在除夕夜和我分手了。我跟你们说了，很俗套吧。我真的没预料到，也绝对不希望发生这种事。他说，你会没事的。我只是不停地哭。我想阻止它，修复它。我努力在内心深处寻找合适的词句，然后脱口而出的却是：“你怎么能让我就这样走开？我是唯一真正了解你的人。”我是认真的。事实上，我甚至可以说，在那一刻，没有人能比菲尔·柯林斯更好地传达我的感受。
(SINGING) Take a good look at me now 'cause I'll still be standing here. And you coming back to me is against all odds. It's the chance I've got to take.
（演唱）现在好好看看我，因为我还会站在这里。而你回到我身边几乎是不可能的事，这是我必须去冒的险。
If I thought I'd been in the Phil Collins phase before, it was nothing compared to what came next. I was no longer listening to a song for pleasure, but for pain. They were breakup songs, and hearing them was the only thing that made me feel better. And by better, I mean worse.
如果说之前我对菲尔·柯林斯的狂热已经够深了，那之后的一切更是有过之而无不及。我不再是为了愉悦而听歌，而是为了感受痛苦。那些都是分手情歌，听着它们是唯一能让我觉得好过点的方式。这里的“好过点”是指感觉更糟了。
There's something so satisfying about listening to sad songs. They're like how you would actually be spending your day if you were allowed to just break down and sob and grab hold of everyone you met. They make you feel less alone with your crazy thoughts. They don't judge you. In fact, they understand you.
听悲伤的情歌有种莫名的满足感。它们就像是如果你真的允许自己崩溃痛哭，并向见到的每一个人寻求慰藉时，你一天会真实度过的方式。它们让你觉得在这些疯狂的想法中你并不孤单。它们不会评判你，事实上，它们理解你。
A breakup song won't ever suggest you start online dating or that you're better off without him. They tell you that you're worse without him, which is exactly what you want to hear because it's how you feel. I didn't want to be cheered up. I didn't want to bounce back. I didn't want to meet someone new. I wanted to wallow, big time, deeply, and with the least amount of perspective possible. And the only way to do that was by turning off my phone and turning up the sad, sad music, like this song that I love by the band The Magnetic Fields.
分手情歌永远不会建议你开始网上约会，或者告诉你没有他你会过得更好。它们告诉你，没有他你反而更糟，而这正是你想听的，因为那正是你的感受。我不想振作起来。我不想反弹。我不想去认识新的人。我只想彻底地、深陷地沉溺，并且尽可能地拒绝任何理性视角。而要做到这一点，唯一的方法就是关掉手机，把悲伤的音乐开到最大声，比如我这首非常喜欢的磁场乐队（The Magnetic Fields）的歌。
(SUBJECT) THE MAGNETIC FIELDS: (SINGING) I don't want to get over you. I guess I could take a sleeping pill and sleep at will and not have to go through what I go through. I guess I should take Prozac, right? And just smile all night at somebody new, somebody not too bright, but sweet and kind, who would try to get you off my mind. I could leave this agony behind, which is just what I'd do if I wanted to, but I don't want to get over you.
（磁场乐队演唱）我不想忘记你。我想我本可以吃一片安眠药，想睡就睡，不必经历我所经历的一切。我想我应该吃百忧解，对吧？然后整晚对某个新的人微笑，虽然那个人不够聪明，但既甜蜜又善良，会试图让你从我的脑海中消失。我可以抛弃这份痛苦，如果我想要的话，我完全可以做到，但我不想忘记你。
It's great because the lyrics perfectly articulate this feeling you didn't even know you had. Then there's the Bonnie Raitt song, "I Can't Make You Love Me."
这太棒了，因为歌词完美地表达了你甚至不知道自己拥有的那种感觉。然后还有邦妮·莱特（Bonnie Raitt）的那首《I Can't Make You Love Me》。
(SINGING) I'll close my eyes, then I won't see the love you don't feel when you're holding me.
（演唱）我会闭上眼睛，这样我就看不见当你抱着我时，你心中感受不到的爱。
The song was written by Mike Reid and Allen Shamblin after they read this little article in the newspaper about a guy who'd gotten drunk and shot up his girlfriend's car. At his sentencing, he was asked if he learned any lessons from what he'd done. And he said, "Yes. You can't make a woman love you if she don't."
这首歌是迈克·里德（Mike Reid）和艾伦·沙姆林（Allen Shamblin）在报纸上读到一则小新闻后写的，讲的是一个男人喝醉了酒，把女朋友的车开枪打烂了。在判刑时，他被问到是否从所做的事情中吸取了任何教训。他说：“是的。你无法强迫一个女人爱你，如果她不爱的话。”
(SINGING) 'Cause I can't make you love me if you don't. You can't make your heart feel something it won't.
（演唱）因为如果不想爱，我无法强迫你爱我。你无法强迫你的心去感受它不愿感受的东西。
Before the breakup, I had no idea how much breakup music was out there. For example, every song ever written. Or at least every third. But once you're heartbroken, you notice it everywhere. You find yourself in the supermarket, listening to a song you've heard before, but never really heard, thinking to yourself, it's just so true.
分手前，我根本不知道市面上竟然有这么多分手情歌。比如，曾经写过的每一首歌，或者至少三分之一是。但一旦你心碎了，你到处都能听见。你会发现自己在超市里，听着一首你以前听过但从未真正留意过的歌，心里想：真是太贴切了。
(SINGING) In my life, there's been heartache and pain. I don't know if I can face it again. Can't stop now. I've traveled so far to change this lonely life. I wanna know what love is.
（演唱）在我的人生中，有过心痛和痛苦。我不知道我是否能再次面对它。不能停止现在，我已经走了这么远，去改变这孤独的生活。我想知道什么是爱。
It's not just that you overlook the cheesiness. You embrace it. You do want to know what love is. There's nothing restrained or subtle about being crushed by the person you care most about in the world. It's big and gaudy, and so it only makes sense that songs about it are, too.
这不仅仅是你忽略了它的俗气，你是拥抱了它。你确实想知道什么是爱。被世界上最在意的人伤害，这种感受绝不是克制的或含蓄的。它是宏大且浮夸的，所以关于它的歌也理应如此。
(SINGING) I know you can show me. Ohhh.
（演唱）我知道你能向我展示。哦。
It was after listening to all these songs for months that I knew what I had to do. I had to write one myself. I needed to take charge of my pain. I needed to take wallowing to the next level. It wasn't enough just to be lying on the floor in my pajamas, listening to these songs at 3:00 in the afternoon. I wanted to be the songs. I wanted to be the pain. I wanted to be inside the stereo speakers, to be the sound waves coming into my own head. I wanted to be the thing creating the feeling I was feeling. And I knew just what kind of breakup song I would write.
在听了几个月的这些歌之后，我知道我该做什么了。我必须自己写一首。我需要掌控我的痛苦。我需要把沉溺提升到一个新的水平。仅仅穿着睡衣躺在地板上，在下午三点听这些歌是不够的。我想成为那些歌。我想成为那种痛苦。我想置身于立体声扬声器里，成为进入我大脑的声波。我想成为创造这种感觉的东西。而且我知道我该写什么样的分手歌。
[MUSIC - "YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY YOU LOVE ME" BY DUSTY SPRINGFIELD]
［音乐 - 达斯蒂·斯普林菲尔德的《You Don't Have to Say You Love Me》］
Torch songs are about the most pathetic, desperate, and lonely part of yourself-- the part you'd never admit to your friends, the part of you that knows, without a shadow of a doubt, that you would take him back. Not only that, he wouldn't have to beg or even apologize. Dusty Springfield made a whole career out of these songs. "I Just Can't Make It Alone," "I Only Want to Be with You," "All I See Is You," "Losing You," or this one, which might be the most pitiful sentiment ever uttered out loud.
“诉苦歌”展现的是你身上最可怜、最绝望、最孤独的那一部分——那是你永远不会向朋友承认的部分，是你毫无疑问地知道如果你还有机会，你一定会选择复合的那部分。不仅如此，他甚至不需要乞求或道歉。达斯蒂·斯普林菲尔德（Dusty Springfield）靠这类歌成就了一番事业。《I Just Can't Make It Alone》、《I Only Want to Be with You》、《All I See Is You》、《Losing You》，或者这首，这可能是历史上最卑微的情感表达了。
(SINGING) You don't have to say you love me. Just be close at hand. You don't have to stay forever. I will understand. Believe me. Believe me. I can't help but love you. But believe me. I'll never tie you down.
（演唱）你不必说你爱我。只要在我身边就好。你不必永远留下来。我会理解的。相信我。相信我。我忍不住爱你。但相信我。我绝不会束缚你。
It's just so pathetic. And deep down, it's how I felt, too. And it felt good to have someone just come out and say it. There are some words you can never speak, but somehow you can sing.
这真是太可怜了。但内心深处，这也是我的感受。有个人能直接说出来，感觉真好。有些话是你永远说不出口的，但不知为何，你可以唱出来。
So I knew what kind of song I was going to write, but I had no idea how to go about writing it. I needed some advice. And out of thousands of musicians who write about heartbreak, there was only one I cared to talk to.
所以我知道我要写什么样的歌，但我不知道该怎么写。我需要一些建议。在成千上万写过心碎情歌的音乐人中，我只想和一个人谈谈。
Hi.
喂。
你好。
Hi, Starlee. Can you hear me OK?
你好，斯塔莉。能听清我说话吗？
Yeah, I can hear you great.
能，听得很清楚。
Phil Collins, of course. What? Is that weird? I got it into my head that it'd be great to ask Phil Collins how to write a breakup song, the same way you might think to yourself, I'd really love to talk to Michael Jordan about free throws. I never thought it would actually happen.
菲尔·柯林斯，当然是他。什么？这很奇怪吗？我脑子里冒出一个念头，觉得如果能问问菲尔·柯林斯怎么写分手歌该多好，就像你可能会想：真希望能和迈克尔·乔丹聊聊罚球一样。我从没想过这事真的会发生。
Then, against all odds, it turned out I had a friend who was on the road with Phil Collins, on his Genesis reunion tour, shooting footage for the DVD extras. He gave me his contact info, and I sent him an email. "Dear Mr. Collins, I have a rather unusual request." Then I waited, refreshing my inbox every three seconds.
然后，出乎意料的是，我有个朋友正好在菲尔·柯林斯的巡演团队里，那是“创世纪”乐队的重聚巡演，他在拍摄DVD花絮。他给了我联系方式，我发了封邮件过去。“亲爱的柯林斯先生，我有个不同寻常的请求。”然后我就在那儿等着，每三秒刷新一次收件箱。
When his email finally appeared, he was friendly and casual. We set up a time to talk. In my mind, he was already so intimately involved in my breakup that it seemed crazy that he didn't actually know about it. So I told him.
当他的邮件终于出现时，他很友好、很随意。我们约好了通话时间。在我心目中，他已经深刻介入了我的分手过程，以至于他竟然不知道这件事，让我觉得不可思议。所以我告诉了他。
Well, I'm going to tell you the whole story of my breakup and stuff, OK? Is that OK?
嗯，我要把分手的故事等等都告诉你，好吗？可以吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it's your 45 minutes. [LAUGHS]
好的。那是你的45分钟时间。[笑声]
OK. Well, it also involves you. So I was dating my boyfriend, Anthony, and he kind of broke up with me on New Year's Eve.
好的。嗯，这也和你有关。我当时在和男友安东尼交往，他在除夕夜跟我分手了。
Oh, nice. Yeah.
哦，真不错。是的。
Whereas before, it was Anthony and I talking about Phil, now it was Phil and I talking about Anthony. Actually pretty tidy, when you think about it.
以前是安东尼和我谈论菲尔，现在变成了菲尔和我谈论安东尼。说起来其实挺顺理成章的。
And at one point, I turned to him and it just flew out of my mouth. I just looked at him and I was like, I can't believe you're just going to let me--
有一次，我转向他，话就脱口而出。我看着他说：“我不敢相信你竟然就这样让我……”
Walk away?
“走开？”
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
对。[笑声]
And before long, Phil Collins and I were commiserating about heartbreak, which he also went through recently.
没过多久，菲尔·柯林斯和我开始一起感叹心碎，他也刚刚经历过这些。
So I mean, I've just been through a marriage breakup. And you talk about New Year's Eve. My divorce was final on my birthday.
我是说，我刚经历过一次婚姻破碎。你说到除夕夜。我的离婚是在我生日那天生效的。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
And I didn't want it at all. So that's something that-- you know, you always remember these things. Like you'll always remember New Year's Eve, and I'll always remember my birthday.
我根本不想要这个结果。所以，你知道，这些事情你总是会记住的。就像你永远会记得那个除夕夜，而我永远会记得我的生日。
I know. It makes me want to skip those dates, doesn't it?
我知道。这让人想跳过这些日期，不是吗？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的，确实。
Up until this conversation, I never thought I had much in common with Phil Collins. He started playing in Genesis at the age of 19. I didn't. He performed in Live Aid, while I only watched it on TV. He was in the movie Buster, which I never actually saw.
在这次谈话之前，我从没觉得我和菲尔·柯林斯有什么共同点。他19岁就在“创世纪”乐队演奏了。我没有。他在“拯救生命”慈善演唱会上演出，而我只是在电视上看。他演过电影《巴斯特》，但我甚至没看过。
But talking to him was easy. He told me that, when he was in Genesis, he just played drums and sang. He didn't write. "Against All Odds" was one of the first songs he wrote himself, when he was working on his first solo album.
但和他交谈很轻松。他告诉我，当他在“创世纪”乐队时，他只是打鼓和唱歌，并不写歌。《Against All Odds》是他创作的第一首歌，当时他正在制作第一张个人专辑。
That song, particularly, was written during my first divorce. My first wife and the kids had gone, and I was just left there. So it was written totally out of experience as opposed to "this is a what-if" song. You know what I mean?
那首歌尤其是在我第一次离婚时写的。第一任妻子和孩子们离开了，只剩下我一个人。所以那完全是出自真实体验，而不是一首“如果……会怎样”的歌。你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Do you think you could have written that song if your wife hadn't left?
明白。如果你的妻子没离开，你觉得你能写出那首歌吗？
Probably not. I mean, frankly, if that personal stuff had not happened to me at that time, I probably would never have made an album. And if I was to have made an album eventually, it would have been more of a jazz/rock thing because that was my output. Apart from Genesis, I was in a band called Brand X. And I was a player. So no. Without that stuff, I wouldn't have felt the things I felt that made me sit at a piano night after night, day after day, writing stuff.
可能不能。坦白说，如果当时没发生那些个人变故，我可能永远不会做专辑。即便最终会做，那也更偏向爵士/摇滚风格，因为那是我的老本行。除了“创世纪”，我还在一支叫Brand X的乐队，我是个演奏者。所以不，没有那些变故，我不会有那种让我夜以继日地坐在钢琴前写歌的情感。
Did it help?
那有帮助吗？
Well, it helped inasmuch as-- it was kind of, well, when she hears this, it's all going to be OK.
有帮助，因为……当时想着，当她听到这首歌，一切都会好起来的。
Really? Is that what you thought?
真的吗？你是这么想的？
I did, yeah. Foolish, huh? I mean, I did.
我当时确实是这么想的。很傻，对吧？我是认真的。
Did you get over it?
你走出来了吗？
There's various people in your life that you never quite get over. I mean, that's kind of the cliché. And then sometimes, with me, for example, because of children, you are morally obligated, and if you want to be with the kids as much as possible, you have to be in touch with this person that's really hurt you. So it's not like you can just walk away and leave without a trace because, in this instance, there's a couple of little guys that are looking up to you, saying, what am I going to do, Dad?
生活中总有些人你是永远无法完全走出来的。这就是所谓的陈词滥调。有时，比如我，因为有孩子，你在道义上就有义务，如果你想尽可能多和孩子在一起，你就必须和那个深深伤害你的人保持联系。所以这不像你可以直接走开而不留一丝痕迹，因为在这个案例里，有两个小家伙正抬头看着你，问：“爸爸，我该怎么办？”
OK. There are so many crazy things about this. First of all, even Phil Collins can't help but quote Phil Collins. Second, if it hadn't been for his wife leaving him in 1979, Phil Collins would never have become Phil Collins. Heartbreak turned a jazz/rock fusion drummer into an international pop icon.
天哪。这太疯狂了。首先，连菲尔·柯林斯都忍不住引用菲尔·柯林斯的话。第二，如果1979年他的妻子没有离开他，菲尔·柯林斯就永远不会成为菲尔·柯林斯。心碎将一名爵士/摇滚融合鼓手变成了一位国际流行偶像。
But the other crazy thing was how honest and normal he was about it. Once again, Phil Collins put into words what I was feeling. There's a part of me-- and it is not a small part-- that wants my ex, Anthony, to hear the song I write and ask to come back.
但另一个疯狂之处在于他对此是多么诚实和自然。菲尔·柯林斯再次把我感受到的东西用言语表达了出来。我内心深处——而且是很大的一部分——希望我的前任安东尼听到我写的歌后要求复合。
I told Phil that I'd been trying to write my songs, but they just didn't feel right. They were too wordy or something. But when I tried to consult songs that I loved to see how it was done, even the lyrics to the best songs looked flat on the page. I wanted to know how to transform clichéd sentiment into a song that captured the entire range of human emotions. I wanted to know how simple sentences like "love hurts. Love scars" became--
我告诉菲尔，我一直在试着写歌，但感觉总是不对。太冗长了之类的。但当我试图借鉴我喜爱的歌曲看看怎么写时，即使最棒歌曲的歌词放在纸面上也显得平淡无奇。我想知道如何将陈词滥调转化为捕捉整个人类情感范围的歌曲。我想知道像“爱是痛苦，爱是伤痕”这种简单的句子是怎么变成——
(SUBJECT) GRAM PARSONS AND EMMYLOU HARRIS: (SINGING) Love hurts. Love scars. Love wounds and mars.
（格拉姆·帕森斯和埃米卢·哈里斯演唱）爱是痛苦。爱是伤痕。爱是创伤和损害。
Most of the time, it's the direct-- I mean, if it's a good song, what makes it good is the fact that it's-- you know, so many people try to fluff things up or disguise them or make them a little bit too clever, but sometimes it's the simplest thing that actually reaches people.
大多数情况下，这是直接的——我的意思是，如果这是一首好歌，它之所以好是因为……你知道，很多人试图粉饰或者掩盖，或者让它们显得太聪明，但有时正是最简单的东西才真正触动人心。
(SUBJECT) GRAM PARSONS AND EMMYLOU HARRIS: (SINGING) Love hurts. Mm, love hurts.
（格拉姆·帕森斯和埃米卢·哈里斯演唱）爱是痛苦。嗯，爱是痛苦。
It actually looks corny when you look at it on the page.
当你在纸上看到它时，它确实看起来很俗气。
But then, you see, what becomes important then is the way that it's sung.
但你看，重要的是演唱的方式。
Yeah.
是的。
Because otherwise, you get-- and I don't mean any disrespect-- but you get into sort of Michael Bolton territory. And I've got nothing against Michael. I'm just using him as an example. I'm sure people would use me as an example of something that gets overblown and polished as opposed to a simple idea, simply sung, and obviously sounds like it's sung with conviction.
因为如果不这样，你就会……我没有不敬的意思……你会进入迈克尔·波顿（Michael Bolton）的那种领域。我对迈克尔没什么意见，我只是用他作为一个例子。我相信人们也会用我作为一个例子，说某些东西被修饰得过度夸张，而不是一个简单的想法，通过简单的演唱，显然带有信念地唱出来。
So now I had the advice. I had the pain. It was time to start writing. It was pretty terrifying at first. Every single word I put down seemed wrong, even the ones that seemed like they had to go in-- the no-brainers. I'd type the word love, then erase it, and then type it again.
现在我有建议了，我也有痛苦了。是时候开始写了。起初很恐怖。我写下的每一个字似乎都错了，即使是那些看起来理所当然的词——那些不用动脑就能想到的词。我会打出“爱”这个词，然后删掉，然后再打一遍。
Then, one day, I was waiting for the train, and I started thinking about how that train reminded me of Anthony, and then how our love was sort of like a runaway train. Oh, that's good, I thought, and scribbled the line down on the back of my gas bill. Suddenly, heartbreak was flowing out of the cracks in the sidewalk, and it was up to me to transform it into song.
有一天，我等火车时，开始想这列火车怎么让我想起了安东尼，然后想我们的爱情就像一列失控的火车。“哦，这不错，”我心想，然后把这句话写在了煤气费账单背面。突然间，心碎从人行道的裂缝中流淌出来，而我必须将其转化为歌曲。
The next problem was-- and it felt like a small problem, really-- was my complete lack of musical ability. So I asked a guy named Joe McGinty for some help. He's a New York musician who has played with everyone from The Ramones to Ryan Adams to Ronnie Spector. He was in The Psychedelic Furs. He has a million songs. More importantly-- for my purposes, at least-- Joe is a man who understands heartbreak. Here's one of his songs I really like.
下一个问题是——说实话，这感觉是个小问题——是我完全缺乏音乐能力。所以我找了一个叫乔·麦金蒂（Joe McGinty）的人帮忙。他是一位纽约音乐人，和从雷蒙斯乐队（The Ramones）到瑞安·亚当斯（Ryan Adams），再到罗妮·斯佩克特（Ronnie Spector）等所有人合作过。他曾是迷幻皮草乐队（The Psychedelic Furs）的成员。他写过上百万首歌。更重要的是——至少对我来说——乔是一个懂心碎的男人。这是他的一首我非常喜欢的歌。
(SINGING) This song is three weeks old. Guess I should sing it happy birthday. And your image, it still holds a happy accident. I can't seem to shake you from my mind.
（演唱）这首歌已经写了三周了。我想我应该给它唱个生日快乐。而你的形象，仍然像个美好的意外挥之不去。我似乎无法把你从我的脑海中甩掉。
Hi.
你好。
Is anybody else-- glad I got that.
还有别人吗——很高兴我能拿到这个。
I'm good.
我很好。
So I met up with Joe and also Julia Greenberg, a musician and songwriter who plays with Joe a lot. I'd written about a dozen songs, some of them more finished than others. When I printed them out, I had six freshly typed pages of lyrics and then about 15 crazy-looking pages with a few lines here and there, separated by random spaces. I had sent these all off to Joe and Julia before our meeting. Here's Joe reading the one I thought was farthest along.
所以我见了乔，还有朱莉娅·格林伯格（Julia Greenberg），一位和乔经常合作的音乐人和词曲作者。我写了大约十几首歌，有的完成度高一些，有的低一些。当我打印出来时，我有六页刚刚打好的歌词，还有大约15页看起来很疯狂的页面，上面这里那里写着几行字，被随机的空格隔开。在见面之前，我把这些全发给了乔和朱莉娅。这是乔在读那首我以为完成度最高的一首。
OK, "Imaginary Boyfriend." "I can't help but think this all could have been prevented if I'd just gone to a small liberal arts school because then I would have met my imaginary boyfriend at a stand-up comedy open mic. It was love at first eye roll. He said he drew comic books, like David on Roseanne.
好的，“幻想男友”。“我不禁想这一切本可以避免，如果我只是去了一所小型文理学院，因为那样我就能在脱口秀公开麦遇见我的幻想男友。那是一见钟情，始于翻白眼。他说他画漫画，就像《罗斯安家庭生活》里的戴维那样。”
Wow. I thought I'd been working on a song, but I don't even know how to describe what that was. A creative writing class essay, maybe. It was clear that I'd ignored Phil Collins' advice. Keep it simple, not clever. Joe and Julia agreed.
哇。我以为我在写歌，但我甚至不知道该怎么形容那是什么。可能是一篇创意写作课的作文吧。很明显，我忽略了菲尔·柯林斯的建议。保持简单，不要耍小聪明。乔和朱莉娅表示赞同。
I think the "like David on Roseanne" I can't turn into a song.
我觉得“就像《罗斯安家庭生活》里的戴维”那句我没法改成歌词。
When Julia pulled out her favorite of my songs from the very bottom of the stack. I'd been so sure it wasn't a contender that I'd almost not included it at all.
当朱莉娅从那一叠纸的最底层拿出我最爱的那首歌时，我曾确信它根本没竞争力，甚至差点把它删掉。
You had the lyric, "It doesn't do me any good. In fact, it does me bad." It kind of seems impossible to me that that hasn't been in a pop song before. But that's a classic kind of pop song.
你写了这句歌词：“它对我没有任何好处。事实上，它害了我。”我觉得这还没出现在流行歌曲里简直不可思议。但那是一首经典流行歌曲的料。
That's what you look for, right?
这正是你想要的，对吧？
Yeah, that's a classic pop song line.
是的，那是一句经典的流行歌曲歌词。
I have to admit I was skeptical. That lyric was from the crazy pile, just notes for an idea I had for a torch song. I tried to think of the most pathetic scenario I could. What I came up with was this.
我不得不承认我曾表示怀疑。那句歌词来自疯狂的纸堆，只是我为一个“诉苦歌”构思的笔记。我试图想出一个我能想到的最可怜的情景。我想出的是这个：
Anthony goes back to his ex-girlfriend. But rather than letting him go, I agree to be this awkward third wheel, as long as it means still getting to see him occasionally. The lines were literally, "I liked you, and you liked her, and I sort of liked her because you liked her." Julia had run with the idea, with one minor change.
安东尼回到了前女友身边。但我没有让他走，而是同意做这个尴尬的电灯泡，只要这意味着偶尔还能见到他。歌词实际上是，“我喜欢你，你喜欢她，而我因为你喜欢她所以也稍微喜欢她。”朱莉娅沿着这个思路继续，只做了一个微小的改动。
You know that you had it all "like," and I changed it to "love." That was the biggest--
你知道你原来用的是“喜欢”，我把它改成了“爱”。那是最大的……
God, that makes-- I feel like there's something really, deeply-- there are like even more issues that I have to work out with myself that I put "like" and not "love." It didn't even occur to me.
天哪，那让我觉得……我感觉我对自己身上还有一些更深层次的问题要处理，我用的是“喜欢”而不是“爱”。我甚至没意识到。
Julia had been so sure it was an actual song that she'd gotten to work before our meeting. She'd sketched out a melody and sung it to Joe on his answering machine. They played it for me.
朱莉娅确信那是一首真正的歌，所以在我们见面之前她就开始工作了。她起草了一段旋律，并在乔的电话录音机里唱给他听。他们把它放给我听。
Yeah, all right. This is going to be a rough--
好，没问题。这会是一个草稿……
It's very rough.
非常粗糙。
--rendering of the opus. Yeah, OK.
……作品的呈现。好的。
(SINGING) I loved you, and you loved her, and I sort of loved her 'cause I love everything you loved. Then she stops, stops loving you, and glory, hallelujah, somehow you start loving me. And I don't know why I love you. I just do. I really do. And it doesn't do me any good. In fact, it does me bad. And you're oh so gone. And I'm oh so sad.
（演唱）我爱你，你爱她，而我因为你爱的一切，所以也稍微爱她。然后她停止了，停止爱你，荣耀归于哈利路亚，不知何故你开始爱我了。我不知道我为什么爱你。我就是爱。我真的爱。这对我没有任何好处。事实上，它害了我。而你已经走得那么远。我是那么悲伤。
So yes, in theory, I knew all this, that music was important. It transforms words, unites the universe together. But I'd never actually seen it happen in front of me.
所以，是的，理论上我明白音乐的重要性。它改变文字，将宇宙连接在一起。但我从未真正亲眼目睹这一过程。
Come up with some more interesting ones.
再想出一些更有趣的。
I cannot believe that's the one that you choose. But then, when you were singing it, it was like the words were like flying off the page, and there was like pixie dust on them or something, like a magic spell had-- you tapped it with a wand. And it makes total sense now after hearing it that that should be the one.
我不敢相信那是你选的那一首。但在你唱它的时候，感觉歌词就像从纸上飞了起来，上面像是撒了仙尘或者别的什么，就像一个魔法——你用魔杖轻轻点了一下。在听完之后，这完全说得通，它就该是这一首。
So now the three of us had written a song about the other three of us. Over the next week, we finessed the lyrics, tweaked the melody, and recorded the song. It seemed obvious who should get the first listen. And no, I don't mean Anthony. That'd be crazy. I mean Phil Collins.
所以现在我们三个人写了一首关于我们另外三个人的歌。接下来的一周里，我们润色了歌词，调整了旋律，并录制了这首歌。谁该第一个听，似乎显而易见。不，我不是指安东尼。那太疯狂了。我是指菲尔·柯林斯。
Can I play my song for you? Is that OK? I don't want to put you on the spot and make you--
我能为你唱我的歌吗？可以吗？我不想让你感到尴尬，让你……
No, no, no, I would like to hear it. We've been talking about it?
不，不，不，我很想听。我们一直在谈论它，对吧？
Really? OK, cool. And just be honest.
真的吗？好的，太棒了。而且要说实话。
OK.
好的。
Oh, OK. Here it goes.
噢，好的。开始了。
So I played him the song. I'll skip the part you've already heard and the bridge and jump right to the end.
所以我给他放了那首歌。我会跳过你们已经听过的部分和过渡段，直接跳到结尾。
(SINGING) Now it's just the three of us. The names may have changed, but the sorry facts remain the same-- that I love you, and she loves you. I'm OK with second best. Just love her more and love me less. I don't know why I love you. I just do. I really do. It doesn't do me any good. In fact, it does me bad. 'Cause you're oh so gone, and I'm oh so sad. You're oh so gone, and I'm oh so sad.
（演唱）现在只剩下我们三个。名字可能变了，但遗憾的事实依然如故——我爱你，而她也爱你。我能接受屈居第二。只要多爱她一点，少爱我一点。我不知道我为什么爱你。我就是爱。我真的爱。这对我没有任何好处。事实上，它害了我。因为你已经走得那么远。我是那么悲伤。你走得那么远，我是那么悲伤。
Well, well. There's some great stuff in there. I really like-- what's the line about doing me no good. In fact, it's doing me bad?
嗯，真不错。里面有一些很棒的东西。我真的很喜欢……关于“对我没有好处。事实上，它害了我”的那句歌词是什么？
"It doesn't do me any good. In fact, it does me bad."
“它对我没有任何好处。事实上，它害了我。”
Yeah. That's fantastic.
是的，太精彩了。
Really?
真的吗？
And afterwards, the line that says, and you're oh so gone. I laughed when I heard that. "You're oh so gone, and I'm oh so sad." I mean, it's just really smart.
还有后来那句“你已经走得那么远”。听到这儿我笑了。“你走得那么远，我是那么悲伤。”我的意思是，这真的很高明。
I can't believe it. That's so nice of you. I can't-- this is like the--
我不敢相信。你太好了。我不……这就像……
It's not being nice. I just like it. I mean, I would easily have said, hey, it's not for me, you know? But I heard it, and I thought there was some very-- it's very funny. It's very clever.
这不是客套。我只是真的很喜欢。我的意思是，如果我不喜欢，我会直接说的，你知道吗？但我听了之后，觉得它很棒……它很有趣。很聪明。
Thank you. Well, that's what I mean, though, about how, like I told you, I was trying to write all these crazy concepts and conceptual ideas, and then the one that seemed to work was just the one that's how I feel.
谢谢。不过，这就是我想说的，正如我告诉你的，我试图写各种疯狂的概念，但最终奏效的那一个只是真实感受。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you think he'll come back?
你觉得他会回来吗？
I hope so because you obviously do feel a lot for him.
希望如此，因为你对他显然投入了很多情感。
Oh. Do you think I'll ever stop feeling bad, like I am now?
哦。你觉得我会停止这种糟糕的感觉吗？像现在这样。
But you kind of like feeling bad, don't you?
但你其实有点享受这种糟糕的感觉，不是吗？
Oh yeah. Well, it's something--
噢，是的。嗯，这感觉……
I don't think you really want to get over it. I think you're kind of enjoying it. So that's kind of a dilemma you have to sort out.
我不觉得你真的想走出来。我觉得你还在享受这种状态。所以这是你必须处理的困境。
You really have me pegged. It feels important or big or something. Like I felt so much for him when I was with him, and the only way to still feel like that strongly about something is to not let it go. I would love to be the person who was just like, he meant nothing to me. But instead, I'm the person who's like, OK, I'm going to write a breakup song and play it over the airwaves. I've like lost all my cool.
你真的看穿我了。这感觉很重要，很宏大。就像我和他在一起时对他投入了那么多，而还能对某件事保持那种强烈感受的唯一方式，就是不让它过去。我真希望能成为那种说“他对我什么都不是”的人。但相反，我成了这种人：好吧，我要写一首分手歌，还在广播里播放。我完全失去了我的酷劲。
Well, I don't see it like that.
嗯，我不这么看。
Really?
真的吗？
You're just addressing something you need to address, and this is, amongst other things, getting it out of your system. You've had the satisfaction of actually getting something tangible that you can play out of this relationship.
你只是在处理你需要处理的事情，除其他事项外，这是把它从你的系统中排解出来。你获得了从这段关系中得到某种有形的东西并可以播放出来的满足感。
That's true. But don't you sometimes wonder like, is it better to have the song in the end or the relationship?
那是真的。但你有时不会想：最终得到一首歌还是得到那段感情比较好？
Oh, no. Surely, you'd rather have the relationship.
哦，不。你肯定宁愿得到那段感情。
Yeah.
是的。
That's the problem.
那才是问题所在。
But you don't have the choice.
但你没得选。
Now that the song is done, it's really hard not to wonder if Anthony is going to hear it. I'd like to say I've gone back and forth on whether I even want him to, but the truth is, of course I do. Everyone I talk to, from my best friend all the way to Phil Collins, says he'll listen. And yes, if the roles were reversed, and it were me, I definitely would. But I know Anthony. If anyone could resist listening, it would be him. You're just going to have to trust me on this one.
现在歌写完了，很难不去想安东尼会不会听到。我很想说，关于我是否真的想让他听到，我反复思量过，但事实是，我当然想。我交谈过的每一个人，从我最好的朋友一直到菲尔·柯林斯，都说他会听的。是的，如果角色互换，是我，我也一定会听。但我了解安东尼。如果有什么人能抗拒不听，那一定是他。关于这个，你们只能相信我。
Which doesn't mean I think he'll never hear the song. I can see him keeping a copy of it in some box stuffed with mixtapes and copies of SAT scores so that he can listen to it one day when he's ready. I picture him 40 years from now, an old man living in some house that I'll never see, which breaks my heart. In my head, he doesn't look like a real old man, but like a young one wearing stage makeup. I imagine him sitting down to finally listen on the CD player that people make fun of him for still having. He loads it in and hits play. He listens to the entire song from start to finish. And when it's over, he plays it again and again until the tears are running down his face.
但这并不意味着我觉得他永远不会听到这首歌。我能想象他把这首歌的拷贝存在某个塞满了混音带和SAT成绩单的盒子里，以便在某天他准备好时听上一听。我想象40年后，他成了一个老头，住在我永远不会见到的房子里，这让我心碎。在我的脑海里，他看起来不像个真正的老头，而像个画着舞台妆的年轻人。我想象他坐下来，最终在人们嘲笑他至今还在使用的CD播放机上听这首歌。他放进去，按下播放键。他从头到尾听完整首歌。当结束时，他一次又一次地播放，直到泪水流下他的脸庞。
Starlee Kine.
斯塔莉·凯恩。
[MUSIC - "IF YOU EVER NEED A STRANGER (TO SING AT YOUR WEDDING)" BY JENS LEKMAN]
［音乐 - 延斯·莱克曼的《If You Ever Need a Stranger (To Sing at Your Wedding)》］
You can hear more stories from Starlee Kine on her podcast Mystery Show. Coming up, a big city mayor, an eight-year-old girl, and a dog weigh in with their solutions to getting over your next breakup. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
你可以在她的播客“神秘秀”（Mystery Show）里听到更多斯塔莉·凯恩的故事。接下来，一位大城市市长、一个小女孩和一只狗将分享他们解决失恋问题的方案。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Break-Up," stories from inside the vortex of shockingly contradictory feelings that happen after a breakup.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，我们都会选定一个主题，并带来各种围绕该主题的故事。今天的主题是“分手”，讲述那些分手后陷入令人震惊的矛盾情绪之中的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, But Why?
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，为什么？
After a relationship ends, you can puzzle for years over why things went wrong and did they have to. And you yearn for a simple story that explains it. And that's not just true for the people in the relationship. It's true for the kids. And now, with that thought, let's flip on the radio time machine.
一段关系结束后，你可能会琢磨很多年为什么事情会出错，是不是本可以避免。你渴望有一个能解释这一切的简单故事。这不仅适用于关系中的成年人。对于孩子们来说也是一样。带着这个念头，让我们按下广播时光机的开关。
Reforming welfare in this half hour. This is Noah Adams.
本半小时将重塑福利制度。我是诺亚·亚当斯。
And I'm Renee Montagne with All Things Considered.
我是蕾妮·蒙塔尼，收听《综述》（All Things Considered）。
The welfare reform that they're talking about here is that of President George Herbert Walker Bush. The day that this aired, February 11, 1987, I was one of the lower-level producers at All Things Considered. But that day, I got to work on this story about breakups that I still think about, a story about somebody who was wanting to understand a breakup and reaching out to various people out in the world to do that-- in a way, like Starlee did.
他们这里提到的福利制度改革是乔治·赫伯特·沃克·布什总统的。那期节目播出的那天是1987年2月11日，我当时是《综述》的一名基层制作人。那天，我参与制作了这个我至今仍记忆犹新的分手故事，一个关于某人想要理解一次分手，并向世界上的各种人寻求答案的故事——某种程度上，就像斯塔莉所做的那样。
So OK, all you need to know is it's 1987. Edward Koch is the mayor of New York City. Noah Adams is one of the hosts of All Things Considered at the time, and he does the interview.
好的，你只需要知道那是1987年。爱德华·科赫是纽约市长。诺亚·亚当斯是当时《综述》的主持人，他负责了这次采访。
Betsy, tell me your full name, please.
贝茜，请告诉我你的全名。
Betty Allison Walter.
贝蒂·艾莉森·沃尔特。
Betsy Allison Walter. And you're eight years old?
贝茜·艾莉森·沃尔特。你今年八岁？
Almost nine.
快九岁了。
And you live in Manhattan?
你住在曼哈顿？
Mhm.
嗯。
And you're in our studio in New York. I appreciate you taking some time to come in and telling us this story. You wrote a letter to the mayor of New York, Mayor Koch.
你现在在我们在纽约的演播室里。我很感激你能抽时间来这里讲讲这个故事。你给纽约市长科赫市长写了一封信。
Right.
是的。
Tell me about that, please.
请告诉我关于这封信的事。
Well, I wrote to him because my parents are getting divorced, and I really don't know who to turn to. And I just told him that my parents are getting divorced and my dad is with somebody else. And I was just really used to something and now this. And it's really kind of hard on me. And I'd like an opinion.
嗯，我写信给他是因为我的父母正在离婚，我真的不知道该找谁谈。我只是告诉他我的父母要离婚了，爸爸现在和另一个人在一起。我以前非常习惯某些生活，现在却变成了这样。这对我来说真的很艰难。我想听听他的看法。
Why did you write to Mayor Koch?
你为什么写信给科赫市长？
Because he's somebody who I've thought, he's very good to us, I guess, because he's the mayor, and he knows a lot of things. And I thought he would know about this, too.
因为我觉得他是一个非常好的人，我想是因为他是市长，而且他知道很多事情。我觉得他应该也了解这些事。
Yeah. Did you get an answer back?
是的。你收到回复了吗？
Yes.
收到了。
What'd he say?
他说什么？
It's very short. "Thank you for the letter. I was saddened to learn of the difficult times you are experiencing now. It is important for you to share your feelings and thoughts with someone during this time. I wish there was an easy solution to these problems, but there is not. Please remember that you are loved and that people care about you. All the best. Sincerely, Edward Koch."
很短。“感谢你的来信。得知你现在经历的艰难时刻，我感到很难过。在这段时间里，和某人分享你的感受和想法是很重要的。我希望这些问题有一个简单的解决方法，但并没有。请记住你是被爱的，有人在关心你。祝好。诚挚地，爱德华·科赫。”
That's nice. Was that reassuring to you in a way?
真不错。这在某种程度上让你感到安慰吗？
No.
没有。
No? Did you have any thought in your mind that perhaps he could actually do something about it? For example, call your father and get your mom and dad back together?
没有？你脑子里有没有想过，或许他真的能做点什么？比如，给你的父亲打个电话，让你妈妈和爸爸重归于好？
No.
没有。
No? You just wanted some advice.
没有？你只是想寻求一些建议。
But see, I try to sometimes like-- because I had a dance recital one day, and I invited them both, but I wanted them to sit next to each other, but they didn't.
但是，你看，我有时尝试……因为有一次我有舞蹈演出，我邀请了他们两人，但我希望他们坐在一起，但他们没坐在一起。
Yeah. What other advice have you been able to come across, to find?
是的。你还找到了什么其他的建议吗？
Well, the guidance counselor, she said that a lot of kids have the same problems. Say there are 400 in school, and like 300 of them have the same problem.
嗯，辅导员说很多孩子都有同样的问题。她说学校里有400人，可能300人都有同样的问题。
Sure. Sure. You know, most people you talk with will have had parents who were divorced.
当然。你知道，你谈过的绝大多数人父母都离过婚。
Oh.
哦。
Yeah, most people. It's kind of a sad thing, but most people get through it all right, too. That's my advice for you.
是的，绝大多数人。这确实是件令人悲伤的事，但大多数人也都挺过来了。这就是我给你的建议。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You wrote another letter to somebody who had written a book called The Boys and Girls Book of Divorce?
你还给另一个人写过信，就是写了《男孩女孩离婚手册》的那个人？
Yes.
是的。
A psychologist?
一位心理学家？
Mhm.
嗯。
And what did that person tell you?
那个人告诉你什么？
Well, he said that I should try another of his books to find out help.
嗯，他说我应该尝试读读他的另一本书来寻求帮助。
Oh, he wanted you to go out and buy his book. Did you?
哦，他是想让你去买他的书。你买了吗？
Well, we had the one he recommended.
嗯，我们有他推荐的那本。
And how did that go? What did you think of that one?
感觉怎么样？你觉得那本书如何？
Well, the problem is he puts things in a way that I can't quite get it through me, that I already know. And I want some real advice that my questions really are, not just answers that people keep telling me over and over again.
问题是他表达的方式让我无法接受，有些我已经知道了。我想要一些真正的建议，针对我的问题，而不是人们一遍又一遍告诉我的那些答案。
Can you give me an example, Betsy?
贝茜，你能给我举个例子吗？
Why did they get divorced? What happened?
他们为什么要离婚？到底发生了什么？
Do you think that parents sometimes don't think children are old enough to understand or can't handle it and so will hide some information?
你认为父母有时会觉得孩子不够大，听不懂或承受不了，所以会隐瞒一些信息吗？
Yes.
是的。
Not that they have to say everything, but you think there ought to be a little bit more sharing of the information?
并不是说他们必须全说出来，但你觉得应该多分享一点信息吗？
Yeah. That's what my mom said.
是的，我妈妈也这么说。
Yeah. And in terms of their own divorce, do you understand it better now?
在他们自己的离婚这件事上，你现在理解得更好些了吗？
No.
没有。
No? Why? What still don't you understand about that?
没有？为什么？还有什么是你没理解的？
Well, why did they have to go off and do it? Because see, the most painful part is when I saw my dad packing up. And I really don't understand. It's hard because they won't tell me what happened to them. And I really want them back together. And I don't understand why they can't.
嗯，他们为什么要走上这一步？因为你看，最痛苦的部分是我看到爸爸在打包行李。我真的不理解。这很难，因为他们不告诉我他们之间发生了什么。我真的希望他们重归于好。我不明白他们为什么不能。
Yeah. What do you think you've learned from this? Do you think if somebody else in school, for example, told you that their parents were getting divorced, how do you think you could advise them?
你觉得你从中学到了什么？如果学校里有别人告诉你他们的父母要离婚，你觉得你会怎么建议他们？
Well, I wrote a book, and I think I would say the same information that I said.
嗯，我写了一本书，我想我会说同样的内容。
You wrote a very small book?
你写了一本很小的书？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. Do you have it there?
你带着吗？
Mhm.
嗯。
Could you read some of it for me, please?
能读给我听听吗？
All right. Let me get it. It's called A Book about Divorce. Should I read the whole book? It's short.
好的，让我拿出来。它叫《关于离婚的书》。我应该全读吗？很短的。
Sure.
当然。
"It's not your fault when your parents get divorced. Why does it have to be you? Because Mommy and Daddy don't love each other anymore. Remember, it's OK to be sad and cry. Tell someone about your feelings." That's it.
“父母离婚不是你的错。为什么非要是你？因为爸爸妈妈不再相爱了。记住，感到难过和哭泣都没关系。把你的感受告诉别人。”就这些。
That's nice. Listen, Betsy. Thank you for talking with us. I appreciate it. And I wish you the best. I hope things go well for you.
真好。听着，贝茜。谢谢你接受我们的采访。我很感激。我祝你一切顺利。希望事情能变得更好。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And maybe this is the beginning of a writing experience for you, and you can grow up to be a writer.
也许这是你写作生涯的开始，你长大后可以成为一名作家。
I don't want to. But I want to write like one book that would make it, but not a whole series, you know?
我不想。但我只想写一本书，一本能成功的，而不是写一系列，你懂吗？
You just want to write a book and make a lot of money.
你只是想写本书，赚大钱。
No, not money, just famous.
不，不是钱，只是想出名。
OK. [LAUGHS] OK, Betsy, thank you. Good night.
好的。[笑声] 好的，贝茜，谢谢。晚安。
OK, good night.
好的，晚安。
So that's the tape from 20 years ago. And you're in the studio with us now. Tell us your name.
那已经是20年前的录音了。现在你和我们一起在演播室。告诉我们你的名字。
Betsy Allison Walter.
贝茜·艾莉森·沃尔特。
How old are you?
你今年多大了？
I just turned 29.
刚满29岁。
And you're working?
你在工作吗？
I am. I have been an elementary school teacher for the past seven years.
是的，我做小学老师已经七年了。
How many times over the years do you think you've heard this taped interview?
这些年来你觉得你听过这段采访录音多少次了？
Probably 12. A dozen. Because I didn't hear it for a while. I think I heard it again when I was about 22, 23. Every time I've had a boyfriend, I've played it for him.
大概12次吧，一打左右。因为有一段时间没听了。我想我22、23岁的时候又听了一次。每次我有男朋友，我都会放给他听。
And each time it's got to be different. How's it been changing for you?
每一次听感受一定都不一样吧？这对你有什么改变？
Yeah. Recently was the first change.
是的。最近是第一次有了改变。
Really?
真的吗？
I used to only hear it with my exact inner monologue from when I was there in the studio. And when I heard certain things, I can still remember the exact thoughts running through my head. I remember it very clearly. I remember thinking that you were just another grown-up offering your advice. All these grown-ups kept telling me things, but I felt like I knew what they were going to say. They were going to say, it'll be OK, and people fall out of love. But that wasn't what I wanted to hear. I remember everything. I don't know how.
过去，我听的时候，脑子里只会回响我当时在演播室里的内心独白。当听到某些话时，我还能想起当时的准确想法。我记得很清楚。我记得当时觉得你只不过是又一个提供建议的大人。所有这些大人不停地告诉我各种事，但我感觉我知道他们要说什么。他们会说“会好起来的”、“人们会不爱了”。但那不是我想听的。我什么都记得。我不知道是怎么做到的。
And then recently-- I think it was probably when I graduated college when I heard it again-- I heard it as an adult. And it was so heartbreaking. I didn't think it was sad when it was me. It was just what was going on. And it made me sad to hear pain in my voice, confusion. And now I hear it even differently as an educator. I hear it as, what would I say to her?
然后最近——我想大概是我大学毕业时又听了一次——我以成年人的角度去听。那简直太令人心碎了。当我自己是那个孩子时，我不觉得悲伤。那只是正在发生的事情。听到我声音里的痛苦和困惑让我感到难过。而现在，作为一个教育工作者，我听到的又是另一种感觉了。我在想，我会对她说些什么？
And looking back at that moment, did you really want the truth or did you want things to be well again and whole again?
回顾那个时刻，你是真的想要真相，还是只想让一切恢复正常完整？
I don't believe that I wanted what the truth really was, but I wanted what I had created the truth to be in my head. I wanted them to say something to the fact that, oh, we just needed time apart, and of course we'll come back together. I wanted what I thought the truth was. If I had heard the real truth, I think that it would have been devastating.
我不觉得我想要真相，但我想要我在脑海中构筑出来的真相。我想要他们说出诸如“哦，我们只是需要分开一段时间，当然我们会复合的”之类的话。我想要我认为的真相。如果当时听到真正的真相，我想那将是毁灭性的。
Your dad was fooling around?
你爸爸当时在外面乱搞？
Mhm. And my mom did an amazing job of never, ever putting any blame on him, of always being supportive of us, having a relationship. But if she had said the truth, I couldn't have a relationship with him. I would have been too angry.
是的。我妈妈做得非常了不起，她从没把任何责任归咎于他，总是支持我们，保持关系。但如果她说出真相，我就没法和他保持关系了。我会太愤怒的。
OK, let's imagine this. Your advice just to that eight-year-old Betsy, who was you.
好的，让我们想象一下。你给那个八岁的贝茜——也就是你自己——的建议。
I do grapple with this. It's hard because I know exactly what I wanted to hear when I was eight. I think I would tell her that-- you know what? I would actually say, this is probably how your life is going to be. Your parents made this choice for you. And now, instead of questioning and wondering for so long why this choice was made, how are you going to live your life now, knowing this is your life? I still know myself, and I would have been persistent, wanting answers regardless. But I do think that I needed to feel less helpless.
我也在为此纠结。这很难，因为我完全知道八岁时我想听到什么。我想我会告诉她——你知道吗？我实际上会说：这就是你生活可能的样子。你的父母为你做了这个选择。现在，与其长时间地质疑和好奇为什么要做这个选择，你现在打算如何生活，既然知道这就是你的生活？我了解我自己，无论如何我都会坚持想要答案。但我确实认为，我当时需要感觉到没那么无助。
It's been years since we first broadcast this show, and Betsy Allison Walter is now Betsy New-Schneider. She has two little kids of her own, one of whom is actually near the age Betsy was when she first sat down for her first interview with Noah Adams more than 30 years ago. You can still hear Noah on various NPR news shows.
距离我们首播这期节目已经过去多年了，贝茜·艾莉森·沃尔特现在是贝茜·纽-施奈德了。她自己有两个小孩子，其中一个的年龄，竟然和贝茜当年在30多年前第一次接受诺亚·亚当斯采访时的年龄差不多。你仍然可以在NPR的各种新闻节目中听到诺亚的声音。
[MUSIC - "NOW THAT IT'S LONG OVER" BY BRISA ROCHE]
［音乐 - 布里萨·罗什的《Now That It's Long Over》］
Act Three, Let No Court Put Asunder.
第三幕，让任何法庭都无法拆散。
Now we have this example of somebody trying to make breakups less horrible than they are. Barry Berkman used to be like any divorce lawyer. He fought for his clients. He tried to get them big settlements. But he came to believe that what he was doing actually was not so good for most of his clients, which, you know, was kind of a big problem. Here's the kind of thing he would see. A guy comes in, ready for a divorce.
现在我们有这么一个例子，某人试图让分手变得不那么可怕。巴里·伯克曼曾和任何离婚律师一样。他为客户而战，试图为他们争取大笔赔偿。但他开始相信自己所做的事情对大多数客户来说其实并不好，这，你知道，是个大问题。这是他经常看到的情况。一个人走进来，准备离婚。
His wife had a lot of money. They had worked out a deal, but they did it on their own, without seeing lawyers.
他妻子的钱很多。他们达成了一项协议，但他们是私下达成的，没有咨询律师。
What'd they decide?
他们决定了什么？
And what they decided was that, in order for him-- he was a musician. Didn't have that much money. But in order for him to live close to her and to be able to see the kids, which they both wanted, she was going to give him enough money to purchase a small co-op. And it was great. They were both happy as could be. They were ready to do it.
他们决定，为了让他——他是个音乐人，钱不多——住得离她近点，能看到孩子（这是他们双方都想要的），她会给他足够的钱买一个小公寓。这太好了。他们俩都开心得不得了，准备照做。
They were told to see lawyers. He came to see us. We were fine with it, and we said sure. This looks good. You did a good job. She went to see a lawyer. No way. How can you give him that much? It's not right.
有人告诉他们要咨询律师。他来见了我们，我们觉得没问题，说当然可以，这很好，你们做得不错。她去见了她的律师。不行。你怎么能给他那么多钱？这不对。
That's what her lawyer was saying?
这是她律师说的话吗？
Absolutely. For the lawyer, it was too much because he had an argument which could theoretically end up giving her the greater part of her separate property. She ended up listening to the lawyer. We ended up with a custody fight as well as a divorce fight.
绝对是。对于律师来说，那太多了，因为他有一个论点，理论上可以让她获得她大部分个人财产。最后他们不仅打了离婚战，还打了监护权战。
Wait. And is that because the money fight got so bitter at some point?
等等。这是因为金钱之争在某个时候变得如此激烈了吗？
Exactly.
正是如此。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Then they started fighting over the kids, which they hadn't fought over at all.
是的。然后他们开始争夺孩子，而这本来是他们完全没有争执的地方。
Wait. How did that kick in? Like what was the moment where it went from being just about money to being about the kids, too?
等等。那是怎么演变成这样的？比如，从仅仅关于金钱到也关于孩子，中间的关键点是什么？
What happened was the parties got so angry at each other that they started quibbling about everything. So if he had a gig and couldn't be home on time one evening, she decided he was an unfit parent. If she was spending too much time with her new boyfriend, which this guy decided wasn't appropriate, she became an unfit parent.
发生的情况是，当事人变得太愤怒了，于是开始在每一件事上吹毛求疵。如果他有一场演出，晚上不能准时回家，她就断定他不称职。如果她和新男友在一起的时间太长，而这男人认为不合适，她就成了不称职的母亲。
So the parties ended up fighting not only about money, but about the kids. Used up a good bit of her vast inheritance in the case. And in the end, she ended up buying him the same, or similar, co-op in a similar neighborhood as the one she would have in the first place. But it took a couple of years, embittered everyone, and you had to think, was this worthwhile? Did it have to happen?
所以双方最终不仅为钱争斗，还为孩子争斗。在诉讼过程中花掉了她那大笔遗产中的相当一部分。最后，她还是给他买了同样的，或者类似的、位于类似社区的公寓。但那花了好几年，让每个人都变得愤世嫉俗，你不得不思考：这值得吗？非得发生吗？
Adversarial style divorces make up a ton of all divorce proceedings around the country. And Barry felt like most of those cases ended up like this one-- incredibly expensive, taking a huge emotional toll on everybody, damaging children. So after 15 years of doing these cases like this, he started looking for a different way. And he found something called collaborative divorce.
对抗式离婚占了全国所有离婚程序的很大一部分。巴里觉得大多数案例最终都像这样——昂贵得不可思议，对每个人造成巨大的情感伤害，损害孩子。所以在他做了15年这样的案子后，他开始寻找不同的方法。然后他发现了一种叫“协作式离婚”的方法。
In collaborative divorce, each spouse gets a lawyer, and then the spouses and the lawyers sit down in a room together to work out some kind of agreement. But under the rules of collaborative divorce, if one of the lawyers thinks that the other side is being intransigent or unreasonable, not only can he not threaten to go to court, if it does go to court, he has to give up the case. He has to give the case to another lawyer to do. So the lawyers have an incentive to work everything out.
在协作式离婚中，每位配偶聘请一位律师，然后配偶和律师坐在一起，努力达成某种协议。但在协作离婚的规则下，如果其中一位律师认为对方在无理取闹或不合理，不仅不能威胁要对簿公堂，如果最终真的上了法庭，这位律师必须放弃该案。他必须把案子交给另一位律师来做。所以律师们有动力去解决所有问题。
So OK. They all sit down together, the spouses and the lawyers. And Barry Berkman says that, even though the spouses enter this situation with good intentions of working everything out, the biggest obstacle he has is something very simple.
好的。他们都坐在一起，配偶和律师。巴里·伯克曼说，尽管配偶们带着想要解决一切的良好意愿进入这个过程，但他面临的最大障碍是非常简单的。
I think often what happens is couples in conflict lose the ability to listen to each other.
我觉得往往发生的是，处于冲突中的夫妻失去了倾听对方的能力。
And so you find yourself, very often, saying to your own client, no, no, no, no. Listen to what they're saying.
所以你发现自己经常对你的客户说：不，不，不。听听他们在说什么。
Absolutely. Absolutely.
绝对是，绝对是。
And so one of the things--
所以其中一件事……
Not to agree with it, but at least to understand it. That's the whole question-- to recognize that your point of view doesn't necessarily invalidate your spouse's point of view.
不是要同意它，但至少要理解它。这就是整个问题所在——认识到你的观点并不一定否定你配偶的观点。
You're saying the most important thing people need to do is simply just listen to each other and try to get along.
你是说人们最需要做的事就是简单地倾听对方并尝试相处。
Well, I would say listen to each other. Yeah, I don't know about getting along.
嗯，我会说倾听对方。是的，至于“尝试相处”，我不知道。
They don't have to try to get along.
他们不必非要尝试相处。
Certainly, listening goes a long way.
当然，倾听会大有帮助。
Do things get so reasonable that you get people listening to each other well enough that people eventually just get back together?
事情会不会变得如此合理，以至于人们能倾听得足够好，最终又复婚了呢？
I've had that happen once.
我遇到过一次。
What happened?
发生了什么？
What happened was, we had people who simply couldn't listen to each other. He became very, very busy in his own law practice. She felt she was losing him. Part of it was they couldn't find the time to talk to each other.
发生的情况是，这两人根本听不进对方。他太忙于自己的法律业务了，她觉得自己正在失去他。部分原因是他们找不到时间交流。
But this collaborative divorce process makes you actually show up to meetings with your spouse and your lawyers and start talking. And as these two people talked, they started to see each other's side of things. Maybe he hadn't been around enough. Maybe she could have been more supportive.
但这个协作式离婚过程迫使你真正出席与配偶和律师的会议，开始对话。随着这两个人的交谈，他们开始看到对方的立场。也许他之前陪伴不够，也许她本可以更支持他。
I think the turning point came when they were talking about what to do with the house, and each one kind of recognized that they didn't really want to be living anywhere without the other person.
我想转折点出现在他们讨论怎么处理房子时，每一个人都意识到他们其实并不想在没有对方的地方生活。
Usually, of course, the spouses do not get back together. When the process works, Barry Berkman says, at least they end up feeling a little better about each other.
当然，配偶们通常不会复婚。巴里·伯克曼说，当这个过程起作用时，至少他们最终会对对方的感觉好一点。
Do people ever say, at the end of this process, they appreciate your help and they're glad for the results, but they're still full of pain?
在这个过程结束时，人们会说他们感谢你的帮助，对结果感到满意，但内心依然充满了痛苦吗？
Yeah. I mean, we're not going to get rid of the pain. The pain is there. Long marriages-- the pain is there. I think going through this process enables people to get in touch with that pain and the real sadness that they're experiencing, which is sometimes covered up by their anger.
会。我的意思是，我们无法消除痛苦。痛苦就在那里。长期的婚姻——痛苦就在那里。我认为经历这个过程能让人们接触到那种痛苦以及他们正在经历的真实悲伤，这些有时被他们的愤怒掩盖了。
Are you saying that, at the end of this process, actually just going through the dividing of assets-- which is really, in the end, all you're trying to do-- actually makes people's anger dissipate? When you do it this way?
你是说在过程结束时，仅仅通过资产分割——这最终确实是你试图做的所有事情——实际上让人们的愤怒消散了？当你用这种方式做的时候？
I think going through the process, where we reach-- and it's not just the assets. The assets are usually relatively easy. Don't forget we have the kids and the parenting and the decision-making. That's often a lot tougher.
我认为经历这个过程，我们达成的……不仅是资产。资产通常比较容易。别忘了我们还有孩子、教养和决策。这通常要困难得多。
I think going through the process where people reach points of understanding, where maybe for the first time they get a glimpse of where the other person is coming from, and so all of the sudden, they realize, you know what? It's not necessary to demonize this person anymore. And when they have those moments of understanding, it goes a long way toward helping them get on with the rest of their lives, actually.
我认为经历这个过程，人们达成理解点，也许第一次窥见了对方的想法，于是突然间，他们意识到，你知道吗？没必要再把这个人妖魔化了。当他们有了那些理解时刻，这对帮助他们继续余生大有裨益。
Barry Berkman is a lawyer in New York and a member of the New York Association of Collaborative Professionals, which he helped found. Collaborative divorce, by the way, was invented by a Minneapolis lawyer named Stuart Webb.
巴里·伯克曼是纽约的一名律师，也是纽约协作专业人员协会的成员，该协会由他共同创立。顺便说一句，协作式离婚是由一位叫斯图尔特·韦伯（Stuart Webb）的明尼阿波利斯律师发明的。
[MUSIC - "WALKING AWAY" BY BROTHER ALI]
［音乐 - 阿里兄弟（Brother Ali）的《Walking Away》］
Act Four, Divorce Is Rrruuffff!
第四幕，离婚真叫人“汪汪”叫！
We close our show today with this vignette of just how lost you feel when you lose somebody, from Merrill Markoe, recorded on stage at Un-Cabaret in Los Angeles.
今天节目的最后，我们带来这段梅里尔·马可的短剧，讲述当你失去某人时那种迷失的感觉，录制于洛杉矶Un-Cabaret舞台。
Today, our friend Paul came to the house in a near dissociative state of panic. Suddenly and without warning, it appeared that his marriage was unraveling. He sat down on the big, red couch in the living room, and I offered him a vodka as he started detailing his anguish.
今天，我们的朋友保罗几乎处于一种脱节的惊恐状态下到了我家。突然之间毫无预兆，他的婚姻似乎正在瓦解。他坐在客厅那张巨大的红沙发上，我递给他一杯伏特加，他开始详细讲述他的苦恼。
"Up until yesterday, if you'd asked me if my marriage was a happy one, I would have said yes," he said, choking back tears. "And then last night, out of the blue, my wife comes in and tells me she wants a divorce." As Paul spoke, Andy's dog, Puppy Boy, a skinny, brown-and-black Tijuana shepherd, approached with his mouth full of a large, black, completely deflated soccer ball. He placed the flat, wet piece of rubber gently on Paul's knee and then sat down right in front of him to wait for the games to begin.
“直到昨天，如果你问我我的婚姻是否幸福，我会说是的，”他哽咽着说。“然后昨晚，毫无征兆地，我妻子进门告诉我她想要离婚。”保罗在说话时，安迪的狗“小狗男孩”（Puppy Boy），那只瘦弱、黑褐色的蒂华纳牧羊犬，嘴里叼着一只巨大的、黑色、完全瘪了的足球走过来。他把那块平坦、湿漉漉的橡胶轻轻放在保罗的膝盖上，然后坐在他面前等待游戏开始。
Paul was too upset to notice. "She told me she wants to start seeing other men," Paul said, tears welling up in his eyes. "And that's not even the worst of it. Today, I found out from friends they've already seen her around town with another guy. They didn't want to say anything until now." He began to cry. And as he did, Puppy Boy. Attempted to apply a little additional pressure by picking up the deflated piece of rubber off Paul's knee and moving it to a new spot a little further up Paul's leg.
保罗太难过了，没注意到。“她说她想开始见其他男人，”保罗说，泪水涌上眼眶。“这还不是最糟的。今天，我从朋友那儿听说，他们已经看到她跟另一个男人在城里出没。他们一直没想说，直到现在。”他开始哭泣。当他哭时，小狗男孩试图通过把那块橡胶从保罗膝盖上拾起并挪到他腿上另一个更高的位置，来施加一点额外压力。
But Paul had the bad manners to be completely preoccupied by his own tragedy. "I have no idea what I'm going to do," he said, as Puppy Boy moved in a little closer and began staring a little harder, his eyes going intently from the black, flat, rubber thing that was now balancing on Paul's thigh, to Paul's face, and then back to the flat, black, rubber thing, as if to help Paul out in case he was having trouble locating it.
但保罗没礼貌地完全沉浸在自己的悲剧中。“我不知道我该怎么办，”他说，小狗男孩挪得更近了一些，开始更专注地凝视，它的眼睛紧紧盯着保罗大腿上平衡着的那块黑色扁平橡胶，然后又转到保罗的脸上，再转回黑色扁平橡胶上，好像在帮保罗定位，以免他找不到似的。
"It's been just emotionally devastating," Paul continued. "Everything I've worked for has fallen apart. And what happens to me now? Am I going to lose everything-- my house, my cars, my savings?" He broke down and began to sob, the only time I've ever seen this incredibly stoic man cry. Which was the signal to Puppy Boy that the game was finally about to get going.
“这简直是情感上的毁灭，”保罗继续说。“我努力奋斗的一切都崩塌了。我现在怎么办？我会失去一切吗——我的房子、我的车子、我的积蓄？”他崩溃了，开始抽泣，这是我第一次见到这个极其坚忍的男人哭泣。这正是给小狗男孩的信号，暗示游戏终于要开始了。
[LAUGHTER]
［笑声］
So he picked up the deflated soccer ball off Paul's thigh and moved it to the most conveniently located spot of all-- the very center of Paul's lap. Then he sat back down in front of Paul and resumed his intense staring. So he kept doing this for the whole two hours that Paul was at our house.
于是它从保罗大腿上拾起那个瘪了的足球，把它挪到了最方便的位置——保罗大腿的正中央。然后它在保罗面前坐下，恢复了那种专注的凝视。接下来的两个小时，保罗在我家，它一直这么做。
Later that night, after Paul had gone home to pick up the pieces of his shattered existence, I began to wonder what Puppy Boy might have to say for himself about this behavior. So I asked him. Puppy Boy replies, "Hello, new seated person. I am Puppy Boy. And I can see that you are very upset for some reason, but I have something on my mind. I'm going out on a limb here and tell you that it is the most important thing I have ever had to say, and it is this. I have placed a thing on you that you must throw.
那天晚上晚些时候，保罗回家去处理他破碎生活的碎片后，我开始好奇小狗男孩对于这种行为会说些什么。所以我问了它。小狗男孩回答：“你好，新坐着的人。我是小狗男孩。我看得出你因为某种原因非常难过，但我有件事在心里。我要冒险告诉你，这是我这辈子必须说的最重要的事情，那就是：我在你身上放了个东西，你必须把它扔掉。
[LAUGHTER]
［笑声］
If you look down now, you will see it. It is that large, flat thing that is balancing on your knee.
如果你现在向下看，你会看到它。就是那个平衡在你膝盖上的又大又平的东西。
Please listen to me when I tell you that this is an opportunity you cannot pass up. By the way, you have noticed that your knee has a big, flat, wet thing balancing on it, haven't you? Or are you so busy sobbing and weeping and talking about yourself that you are having trouble seeing it? Here's a hint. I'm staring at it right now. So if you can imagine a laser beam coming from my eyes, and then follow it down to the spot on your leg where it is focused, it'll lead you right to it.
请听我说，这是一个你不能错过的机会。顺便问一下，你注意到你的膝盖上平衡着一个又大、又平、又湿的东西了吗？还是你太忙于抽泣、哭泣和谈论你自己，以至于你看不见它了？给个提示：我现在正盯着它呢。所以，如果你能想象我眼中射出激光束，然后顺着它向下看到你腿上聚焦的那一点，它会直接带你找到它。
The only other possible explanation for your puzzling lack of interest is that you are purposefully ignoring me. And why would you do that? Especially since you are really hurting yourself more than you are hurting me because, let's face it, you're the one who's passing up a great opportunity. And by a great opportunity, I'm referring to the chance to have the kind of fun that everyone dreams of having. I speak of the chance to throw a big, flat, stretchy, wet thing. And guess where it is right now?
你之所以对它缺乏兴趣，唯一可能的解释就是你在刻意无视我。为什么要这样做？特别是考虑到你在伤害自己的同时其实也伤害了我，因为说实话，你才是那个错失良机的人。我说“良机”，是指那种每个人都梦寐以求的乐趣。我指的是抛掷一个又大、又平、又有弹性又湿漉漉的东西的机会。你猜它现在在哪？
[LAUGHTER]
［笑声］
Throw it now or live a life of regret.
现在扔掉它，否则余生都在后悔中度过。
I mean, I can't stop you if you'd rather just listen to yourself talk. Wife, wife, wife. She did this. She did that. Really fascinating. For Christ's sakes, look into my eyes and play along! Pick up the big, flat, wet thing. Pick it up! Pick up the big, flat, wet thing. Pick it up. Pick it up. Pick up the big, flat, wet thing. Can you hear me OK? Pick up the big, flat, wet thing. Are you even listening? You know, maybe if you had listened a little better during your marriage, your wife wouldn't want a divorce. Did you ever think of that? It wouldn't surprise me if you never threw the thing she brought you, either."
我的意思是，如果比起和我玩，你宁愿听自己说话，我也没法阻止你。妻子，妻子，妻子。她做了这个。她做了那个。真让人着迷。看在上帝份上，看着我的眼睛跟我一起玩！捡起那个又大、又平、又湿的东西。捡起来！捡起那个又大、又平、又湿的东西。捡起来。捡起来。捡起那个又大、又平、又湿的东西。听得清吗？捡起那个又大、又平、又湿的东西。你到底有没有在听？你知道，也许如果你在婚姻中听得更仔细点，你妻子就不会想离婚了。你考虑过这个吗？如果她带给你的东西你从来都不扔，我也不会感到惊讶的。”
Thank you.
谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
［掌声］
Merrill Markoe at Un-Cabaret in Los Angeles. Merrill's most recent collection of essays is called Cool, Calm, and Contentious. Thanks to Greg Miller of Un-Cabaret.
这是梅里尔·马可于洛杉矶Un-Cabaret的现场表演。梅里尔最近的散文集叫《Cool, Calm, and Contentious》。感谢Un-Cabaret的格雷格·米勒。
[MUSIC - "AGAINST ALL ODDS" BY THE POSTAL SERVICE]
［音乐 - 邮政服务乐队（The Postal Service）的《Against All Odds》］
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Marie, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show was Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production helpfrom Seth Lind, Lygia Navarro, PJ Vogt, and Alvin Melathe. Music help for today's show from Jessica Hopper.
我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，参与人员还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·玛丽、约翰·杰特、莎拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的技术指导是马特·蒂尔尼。制作帮助来自赛斯·林德、莉吉亚·纳瓦罗、PJ·沃格特和阿尔文·梅拉特。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
Special thanks today to NPR. Noah Adams' interview from 1987 was originally broadcast on National Public Radio's All Things Considered, where I was a proud staffer, and was used with permission of NPR. Thanks to Ellen Weiss.
今天特别感谢NPR。诺亚·亚当斯1987年的采访最初是在国家公共电台的《综述》中播出的，我当时是那里的光荣员工，经NPR许可使用。感谢艾伦·韦斯。
Thanks to the musicians who played Starlee's song in Act One-- Joe McGinty on keyboard, Jeremy Chatzky on bass and electric guitar, Julia Greenberg on vocals and acoustic guitar, and Natalie Weiss sings backup. Starlee Kine on tambourine.
感谢在第一幕中演奏斯塔莉歌曲的音乐人们——键盘手乔·麦金蒂，贝斯兼电吉他手杰里米·查茨基，主唱兼原声吉他手朱莉娅·格林伯格，伴唱娜塔莉·韦斯。斯塔莉·凯恩演奏铃鼓。
When we first ran this show, we invited listeners to take the raw tracks of Starlee's song and mix their own versions. The response was kind of incredible-- 129 entries. You can hear the winners of our breakup song contest-- including the version you're hearing right now, by We Were Pirates-- at our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can also listen to-- for free-- any of our old shows in our archive.
当我们第一次播出这期节目时，我们邀请听众利用斯塔莉歌曲的原始轨道，混音出他们自己的版本。反应简直太惊人了——收到了129份参赛作品。你可以在我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上听到我们分手歌曲比赛的获胜者——包括你现在听到的这个由“海盗队”（We Were Pirates）演唱的版本。在网站上，你还可以免费收听我们档案中任何往期的节目。
This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's been listening to the show over the phone this week, and he has some thoughts.
《美国生活》由公共广播交易所（PRX）分发。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他这周通过电话听了节目，并且有一些想法。
Well, well. There's some great stuff in there.
嗯，真不错。里面有一些很棒的东西。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "AGAINST ALL ODDS" BY THE POSTAL SERVICE]
［音乐 - 邮政服务乐队的《Against All Odds》］